um hi i'm allison koenig and i'm
currently doing a postdoc in the msr new
england lab today i'll be talking about
an application of causal machine
learning to fairness which focuses on a
recent paper led by my co-author roshan
chung on federated causal inference
now let's start with some motivation
about why federated causal inference has
to do with fairness so in the us asian
women's breast cancer death rates are
roughly half that of white american
woman
but that said you can see from this
chart that there is a huge amount of
heterogeneity among asian women so for
example incidence is roughly doubled for
japanese women relative to korean woman
in the us so this means we need
increased awareness targeted cancer
control and lots more research to better
understand underlying factors um so
rather than aggregating all of these
very different demographics into one
catch-all asian category which is
potentially inaccurate by subgroup there
are lots of situations where we'd like
to study heterogeneous treatment effects
for each of these very different asian
subgroups recognizing that there's
relatively little medical data collected
for each subgroup alone
right so speaking more generally let's
say that we have two separate sets of
patient data from two different sources
each of them contains rows of patient
data where a subset are patients
belonging to particular subgroups that
we're studying and we let data sets a
and b be heterogeneous so for example
one might have a higher asian
representation than the other now
concretely our research question is how
can we accurately use all of the
information we have in order to estimate
treatment effects on subgroups of
patients who do not appear frequently in
our data
and so the kind of obvious solution here
is for us to simply combine the data
sets this means that we'll have more
data rows that correspond to patients
from the smaller subgroups that we want
to study
but there's a fundamental issue with
doing this in many cases you can't
simply stack the data so for example
you're not allowed to combine medical
claims data from two different companies
for legal and ethical reasons
so what method can we develop instead
given that we can't actually combine
data rows
uh well instead we can do what we've
termed federated causal inference which
doesn't require combining the data sets
themselves so for this we calculate
relevant statistics on each of our data
sets separately and then do some clever
weighting to generate the overall
treatment effect across both data sets
our three federated methods also give us
some nice asymptotic guarantees
and so let's take a step back and think
about just doing causal inference on a
single data set we can estimate a
parametric model using one of three
methods listed uh by maximizing a
weighted likelihood function now why do
we want to estimate these model
parameters because once we have these
parameter estimates we can just plug
them into formulas for standard causal
metrics you might care about like the
average treatment effect ate or the
average treatment effect on the treated
att
now before we proceed to federating our
estimators we need to define some
properties of our data and models so on
covaria distribution
if we have heterogeneous data sets it'll
be unstable
on propensity scores if we're not
simulating our own data these will be
unknown
next if at least one of uh the
propensity or outcome models is unstable
this means that we do not have the same
functional form and model parameters
across individual data sets so we need
to allow parameters to be specific to
each data set and lastly if the model
has omitted covariates or incorrect
functional form then the model is
misspecified
so now let's go through uh with how to
actually federate these estimates so
let's start with our data different data
sets say a and b
and next we use one of our methods say
mle ipw or aipw to estimate the
propensity or outcome model on each data
set separately
then we consider which of the binary
assumptions described earlier actually
holds for the relevant model
and now we get to the key part which is
how to actually federate individual
models with various formulas that we
provide so this involves a bunch of
components like dealing with different
parameters with zero vector padding as
shown in this image
and then it involves weighting estimates
with some combination of hessian sample
size or inverse variance weighting
and so no need to read through this
thoroughly but here's a sample table
from our paper that i'll quickly flash
just so you have a sense of what a form
engine step 4 looks like in terms of how
different assumptions from step 3 affect
the formulas for step 4 that give us the
federated coefficient beta and variance
b
so next is if you've done steps 2 to 4
on propensity models now we go back and
work on the outcome models and finally
the output we get is a federated point
estimate and variants that incorporate
statistics from each data set separately
so the obvious question is you know do
these methods developments actually work
the short answer is yes our paper on
archive includes robustness checks on
both medical data sets and simulations
uh today i'll quickly show one example
in this particular medical application
we want to study the treat the average
treatment effect for a small group of
patients in data set a and a similar set
of patients in data set b
if we estimate the treatment effects on
each of the data sets individually we
get the green and yellow point estimates
where both have a beta hat of less than
zero implying that the treatment appears
to reduce mortality uh the less so for
individuals and datas that be now with
the naive inverse weighting
inverse variance waiting that one might
usually do we get a federated point
estimate this based on the point
estimates of data sets a and b which is
the red dot so the third row there but
this point estimate is further to the
left of the green dot so it doesn't seem
like a very trustworthy combination of
these two data sets and this happens
because data sets a and b are
heterogeneous
uh meanwhile our federated causal method
shows a point estimate between the green
and yellow values which is exactly what
we expect to see if our data sets were
actually combined so overall we suggest
using federated causal inference when
combining data sets if there are legal
or ethical reasons they can't be
combined and this is a straightforward
way to increase power for the subgroups
that you're studying and this is
especially important when those
subgroups have small numbers
so in closing today we've focused on
heterogeneous data set combinations such
that minority patient groups can be more
accurately studied but there are many
more ways in which uh causal machine
learning and fairness intersect and we
hope that researchers will critically
engage with the fairness literature when
conducting causal analyses